Muy buenas tardes Raúl pues
efectivamente Este es el Día de los
asiáticos de probar si pueden o no pasar
por fin a los cuartos de finales es la
tarea que tienen los japoneses dirigidos
por murillazu finalmente pues han sido
una de las sorpresas ganando a España
ganando a Alemania para finalmente estar
aquí enfrentados a los subcampeones del
mundo las esperanzas de Japón están
puestas especialmente Pues en sus
jugadores que han tenido esta mentalidad
de Samurai con la que supuestamente van
a salir hoy una vez más a este campo de
de juego ahora también está Croacia
enfrente ya de hecho pues
el entrenador croata dijo que entendía
muy bien Cuál es la mentalidad que usan
los japoneses cuando van a tener este
tipo de de partidos Así que podemos ver
un choque bastante complicado sobre todo
que Croacia últimamente en las grandes
competiciones a por lo general llevado a
alargue en los partidos y el otro
partido Pues que tenemos es el de Brasil
ante del sur de la canarinha que
finalmente va a tratar de pasar a
cuartos de final parte como favorita
obviamente pero es cierto que no se
puede subestimar a Corea del Sur que
también así como Japón pues ha dado una
gran sorpresa en en este mundial Por una
parte Eh pues eh ganando finalmente a
Portugal en el último partido ya en
extremis con ese segundo gol y de hecho
pues así de digamos de rebotes sacando a
Uruguay de este mundial ahora
contará con Neymar no sabemos si estará
en el banquillo o Silla estará en el
terreno de juego Natalia también
hablemos de otro tema paralelo digamos
al terreno de juego a la cancha una
reventa de boletas que está pasando con
esto
Así es Raúl sobre todo pues todo el
mundo ya está viendo Cuáles son los
partidos los cruces que se están dando
en cuartos Y por ahora el que está
llamando más la atención es el que habrá
entre Argentina y Países Bajos partido
que ha de disputarse este fin de semana
el día sábado y ya sabemos que hay
boletas que se están vendiendo hasta por
cuatro mil quinientos euros casi un 10
10 veces más el valor normal de esta
boletería obviamente están vendiendo
esto con con toda la digamos vendiendo
el afiche diciendo que Perdón que Messi
está en su mejor momento está en su gran
esplendor eso fue lo que nos mostró en
este pasado partido
en octavos Y pues también diciendo que
es la última vez que quizás se le vea en
uno mundial Así que con todo esto han
ido subiendo los precios y bueno eso es
lo que estamos viendo acá con reventa lo
mismo está pasando también con todos los
paquetes VIP que también están
aumentando de precio Así que se está
convirtiendo un poco en el etiquete más
apreciado ir a ver a Lionel Messi en las
diez este próximo fin de semana